quand on installe et ça va ça va bien
mieux ça ça va bien j'ai toujours rêvé
de façon ça faisait il suffisait de pas
toujours tenir votre parole ok je vais
vous demander d'être féroce et boboul
être moi je peux vous dire que ça m'est
arrivé souvent et que ça va m'arriver a
encore qui savait quoi c'est tant mieux
ouais moi je vous souhaite de faire
comme moi parce que ça pourrait changer
votre vie je vous souhaite de ne pas
tenir la première suivante
jamais je vois face ou encore i'm oger
fait plus jamais ça jamais de la ville
vous comprenez le principe
i'm the lich dû souvent ce mot là c'est
dans ma vie j'ai amené mes chances que
j'ai pas eu peur de plus mon orgueil
parce que je serais passé à côté de
moments marquants de ma vie je serai pas
passionné comme je suis aujourd'hui
j'aurais laissé filer des runs la fois
la plus marquante que je me rappelle que
j'ai dit jeanne et je pense que c'est
quand j'étais adolescente la petite voix
intérieure
c'est ma petite voix - mathis voit un
film comparaissent à la mélanine ma
petite voix me l'appeler solange peut
pas vous la trouvez que vous ne trouviez
autres spirituel hockey solage et me dit
tania un jour demeurait sans courir un
marathon avec ton père ok mon père
roulotte aux anarchistes aa à la
question qui seule bonne
moi mon repas les cours des marathons
depuis que tout mais moi moi je ne cours
pas dans
en sauf d'un cours d'éduc là parce qu'on
est obligés de courir faire des courses
d'endurance ou si une bête sauvage me
pourchasse là j'imagine que je vais
couvrir
sinon je ne cours pas le ça va être ma
conscience d'intéressantes qui va par le
fait que imaginez vous une petite voix
qui résonne comme d'un film qu'avec la
personne réfléchir
est ce comme xl le courir si elle bat la
fois que j'ai eu c'est bien courir mais
je m'épate des crises dues par
ventilation mal j'ai mal aux poumons les
gencives me brûle j'arrive toute l'année
dernière il ya juste 0 chance que je
fasse quand mon peuple qui me met à
courir des marathons et gêné en plus là
j'ai un problème au genou
mon exemple et des yeux qui à cause de
tout et c'est cool
j'ai deux cours lire dans mon oreille je
vais pouvoir
je vais pouvoir rien faire waouh mais
quel exemple de détermination cette
fille bref les seconds à passe la vie de
dieu commence je travaille je rencontre
mon job je tombe enceinte genre grèce
je me montre mon premier fils labrecque
est moche capote parce que je dormais
pour le goût de garder mon grandes
maintenant la force d'entendre la fois
en tant de monde chaume qui mon père
parlait de course parce que le cédant 8
matches amicaux parce que mon père
lebret non rocher alors je lui ai dit
quand même pour maigrir je pourrais
peut-être me met à courir courir qu ai
je dit ça - je dis ça après avoir dit
que plus jamais je courais grosse
menteries fait que je m'exécute
je ne viens pas de reining à mon père je
demande à mon job s'il faut que je me
rende pour pour faire réclamant et amy
soir par là une ligne ça se fait très
bien sûr et c'est beau c'est que je
parle
se pose pas facile mais je peux le gros
fan non plus la sangle jemeppe souvent
train de marcher que de cauet je tombais
souvent achiri la ligue l'eau si la
peinture du plus loin à chaque jour
parce qu'elle me semble qu'ils aient
tout est plus loin
après une semaine j'ai réussi enfin à
courir mon premier kilomètre sans
marcher pour vraiment c'était km lol
c'est encore une de mes plus belles
fierté que j'ai autant coureuse puis mes
genoux l'aube et y était mais pour
courir parce que j'ai pu j'ai mary mal
depuis ce temps le sauf la semaine
pendant cinq ans j'ai fait une confusion
mais la chose la plus extraordinaire qui
s'est passé ce jour là c'est que je
réalisais que j'étais capable de courir
fait clavier contenu je m'inscris en
premier demi marathon open eyes ou le
punch je m'inscris premier demi marathon
secours save our thomassin durée en
grèce j'ai gauche qui je continue à coup
je m'inscris à d'autres demi marathon le
groupe des amis du mont autre chose on
se dit on va s'inscrire au marathon et
marathon 42 points 2 km
faut que tu t'entraînes pas mal pour
passer au travers de tout sans trop de
séquelles pas mal trop beaucoup trop à
mon goût
bon je me dis moi trop d'investissements
tinseau non la joie le faire le marathon
où l'eau l'homme a adressé leur fait
plus jamais ce nom car décembre 2010 je
complète mon premier et dernier marathon
à las vegas ou y est super a été faite à
un marathon c'est quand même pas rien
astor je compte juste pour le fun je
fais juste des demi marathon semaine en
masse pas trop de sacrifices 21 km quand
même respectable comme distance
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé entre
eux terme mais je me suis inscrit un
deuxième marathon la mémoire est une
faculté qui oublie qu'on dit et c'est
tant mieux fait que j'ai recommencé à
m'entraîner parce que ça me fait
souffrir pendant quatre heures rendu au
jour j là je me rends compte que
ça vaut mieux que la première fois c'est
mon choix maison avec lego à faire à
manger à changer des couches ça me
permet de prendre l'air
quand je me lève un peu marabout le
matin parce que j'ai passé ma nuit à
allaiter au demi heure le smartphone une
bonne dose de bonne humeur
aïe ça ssl je me sens forte et je suis
capable de le faire
puis je pense que je commence à aimer ça
pour rire et puis le 16 octobre 2011
je réalise mon rêve de cours et/ou mon
marathon et où la glace est fragile avec
mon papa bon vélo à paris voilà c'est
magique réaliser un rêve qu'on comprenne
comme ce sacre et mettent des années à
partir de ce moment là j'ai arrêté de
dire que plus jamais je courais de
marathons j'ai laissé cette porte est
ouverte on sait jamais mais je n'ai
jamais dit que je ne veux plus jamais le
mot gêne non ça je pense que je vois
toujours le dire je me souviens de
l'avoir dit un autre fois j'ai été à
l'arrivée du prestigieux marathon de
boston pour mettre en contexte
boston c'est le rêve de tout les
marathoniens c'est plus vieux marathon
du monde match de cette poule où un
matin que tu te lèves moi je m'écris à
boston non ça il faut que 60 en
qualifications c'est quand même assez
difficile
féculent mois shiloh à côté sa clôture
de métal attendent mon peuple mon chum
parce que d'autres ont assez haute pour
courir à bostens le jardin de ses galops
passer devant un moule à blanche puis je
les envie pas la jeter en admiration
devant les oies ou pas jalouse mouche
convaincu de toute façon avant tout à
rester là je serai jamais l'aube heure
de la clôture de métal en train de
courir le marathon de boston au mois de
janvier 2013 apprend de belles
résolutions je décide d'écraser
définitivement ass gaye moi je fumais
jeu mais pas beaucoup j'ai arrêté par la
migros est ce le chargement c'est que je
prends vaches veux plus je me dis course
mise pour ce voyage fut est touours
population non plus jeter carrera de
fumer mais comme tout mouvement a qui se
respecte
voulait on a tout en parle de prendre du
poids qu'on arrête de fumer fait le jeu
mais je mets deux bombes attendent votre
temps des changes ton alimentation on
peut réduire les portions vont prendre
moins d'alcool aussi par se faire
agresser à l'alcool puisse votre portée
comment cette fumée fait là j'ai une
petite parenthèse pour l'île maurice
dans la salle qui disent ah moi je vais
pas arrêter de fumer parce que je n'ai
pas d'engraisser d'échangés d'arguments
ou changer de technique parce que moi
quand j'aurai tout mais j'ai perdu
presque 30 livres et qui dit perte de
poids quand le corps dit game vitesse
loges mama fly et je m'inscris à deux
marathons cette année l'eau et puis je
fracasse mon record personnel de près de
50 minutes c'est beaucoup quand même
c'est assez pour vous dire que le 20
avril prochain je serai sur la ligne de
départ du marathon de boston a vraiment
pas
j'ai les erreurs que j'ai même pas pensé
pouvoir me permettre de rêver c'est pas
dans ce village depuis ce temps là j'ai
réalisé que moi je t'aime je t'aime fort
de la course si je te me passionner gens
mangent
j'ai été la première femme à compléter
les 104 km du défi iamgold ses parents
val d'or et rouyn
après avoir fini ses plaies c'est
complètement fou train à faire de même
je le pense encore que c'est fou je me
suis dit j'ai des médiums là c'est vrai
plus jamais géré fun à faire de même
quelques mois après je me suis inscrit à
1 5 km en senti arriver la moitié du
parcours j'étais prêt à abandonner je
voulais tout lâché selon les bénévoles
du monde y ait été rendu à la fin il m'a
dit tu n'as moitié de fierté capable je
vais je continuer finalement j'ai
terminé la course puis j'ai terminé
deuxième chez les femmes et puis je me
suis embarqué pas que je publie j'ai
recommencé médecin sous je dirais pas
souffrir le me faire travailler mon
mental puis mon physique de façon
extrême comme ça pendant 16 ans mais
passer les trois quatre jours après
c'est endorphines avec l'afa ce domaine
ben moussa fait mon bonheur ça me rend
de boniments saleh dans ma confiance
j'ai jamais dit que je regarderai pas
les nôtres oui parfois je trouve ça
difficile danger non non ça me tente pas
tout le temps paris me soulier le matin
puis aller courir dehors surtout
température qui fait lula mais c'est
devenu mon mode de vie
je me fixe toujours des nouveaux bus des
nouveaux au rêve
j'ai envie de partager ma passion est
pleinement ces poursuites montre
chaumont et créer un événement qui
s'appelle le trail de gm
c'est un événement de course une marge
de 24 heures sur une boucle de 5 km en
forêt fait que tout le monde paye à son
rythme pendant 24 heures accumulées à
distance qui veut ou qui peuvent n'a pas
assez on a permis à dose participants de
se dépasser de réaliser à quel point
quel corps humain s'est fait fort
quelqu'un qu'on niveau à son rythme on
peut aller pas mal plus loin qu'on s'en
croyait capable c'est votre base à
vesoul
ça veut pas dire que c'est la course
c'est peut-être la peinture c'est
peut-être le piano c'est pas que la
planche à neige mais je sais pas c'est
que vous l'avez jamais essayé ou bien
que vous l'avez ces ips ça peut marcher
plus que vous et moi je recommence
possible et essayer le elles ont
réessayé le laissez vous des chances
laissez-vous du temps c'est en forgeant
qu'on devient forgeron
ces défauts on ignore nos forces parce
que on n'ose même pas essayé oser
essayer de nouvelles choses aux et
écouter leurs vos envies profondes même
si vous pensez que c'est pas fait pour
vous autres si des fois on préfère se
mettre des barrières juste parce qu'on a
peur on n'a pas d'avoir l'air quand on a
pas d'être le moins bon on n'a pas de
mourir c'est pour aimer quelque chose on
n'a pas besoin d'être le meilleur
faut juste aimer sûr on va totalement à
l'écart un jour ou l'autre on va tous
finir en boîte comme dit mon âge ça il
faut profiter de ce que la vie nous
offre pour essayer plein une chose c'est
se lève
des essais des erreurs des passions qui
naissent mollahs j'ai probablement des
je pensais que jamais genre fred exposé
oral de ma vie lâche 7 ha soit je
réalise que je suis capable
finalement j'aï pantoute merci beaucoup
sérieusement merci